hi everyone good morning for all of you
who have rolled out of bed unless you
haven't rolled out of bed and you are
actually doing maths from in bed I don't
know if I approve or disapprove of that
anyhow it's great to have you with us
we're gonna do this lesson a little bit
differently and normally we will do a
lot of worked examples with you but as
you as you probably worked out like
that's that's not easy to do in in this
kind of environment or I should say it's
harder in some particular ways mrs.
Lee's and I were talking about this
yesterday because I'm not getting your
face or your confused sounds of huh like
you know sometimes you'll comment and
say I'm confused but often you'll be
very polite and quietly kind of suffer
in silence so what we're gonna do this
lesson is I'm gonna go through a bit
basically one worked example with you
but if you have a look on the canvas
page and there are more worked examples
and they're just there for you to access
when it's it's appropriate to use so
we're gonna do a with the example
together and then I'm going to set you
loose but once you have a go at the
exercises at a particular point you're
going to start encountering some harder
questions and to help you with them go
to canvas go to the regular class page
you've got hit online learning and when
you go to that regular page where you
see all of our work there the first
thing you'll notice is arm as of this
morning I did put up the notes that I
wrote from yesterday's lesson so you can
see them there on the 6th of May row but
on the 7th of May row you'll see that
I've got some stuff there which we
haven't linked areas between curves is
what we're going to look at shortly that
link will be filled in once there is a
recording which is happening right now
the notes and the homework will also
appear but you'll notice there's
something that's already been linked
there curves with multiple crossings so
this is when you'll see I'll give you an
example of this in a second this is more
difficult and more challenging so it's
for you to have a go out there's two
worked examples in there at length it's
like a 50-minute video ok so what I've
done is I've chosen to give you way more
detail than you probably want but if you
do want to dive dig into the deep into
like what's going on there and how does
it all work there's a there's an
excessive amount of detail there for you
to skip through if appropriate or watch
all of it if you'd like so we're only
going to have the one face-to-face
in here and then you're going to go for
it and I will step mrs. Lee's and I will
stay here doing the entire allotted
period time so if you have questions
you're welcome to come on back but after
I gave you this interest rate we can
Apple it'll be up to you to go for it
all right so that's that let me move
that to one side now and get you back
into the frame of things so we're
looking at compound regions and
yesterday I made this comparison between
the areas of composite figures from
plain geometry so you know circles
rectangles triangles all the rest we're
doing exactly the same thing but with
that wide variety of weird wacky shapes
that we can evaluate we can evaluate the
area because we know integration all
right now we're going to have a look at
a particular variety of compound region
today which is called an area between
two curves and you're gonna have a look
at examples like this so I've called
areas between curves but really it's
kind of a subset of compound regions so
let's have a look at this first example
together all right you can see
immediately Huai has given the name that
it has areas between two curves I've got
two curves here I've provided you with a
pair of parabolas and there's a shaded
region in green there and that's the
thing that we want to evaluate so let me
just give you a brief moment before we
you start tackling the question to
sketch this you always know that is the
first and in some ways most crucial step
everything else you're just asking for
trouble you'll get confused you're not
sure like what does all my algebraic
super mean you need that picture there
okay and I did say this before but I
didn't give many details your graph
needs to be large it needs to be big
enough then you can draw all over all
over it and scribble details and you can
put in coordinates and all the rest
my recommendation is about a third of a
page a third of a page is a good size
for a graph which is gonna have this
much stuff on it okay
another good thing is you know if you
can if you can cover your page yes throw
your graph with your hand and not see
any of the graph anymore it's too small
okay so I should be able to see it that
at least the at least the coordinate
axes poking out the sides of your hand
if I put it right over there okay right
so hopefully that was enough stalling to
get some coordinate axes there the red
you can see is x squared minus 4x plus 5
and the blue parabola is minus x squared
plus 6x plus 17 so how do we chart our
way through this using the knowledge
that we've been developing over the last
week to understand this green area it
might be helpful if we actually see it
without the shading so here's the same
two graphs okay
x squared minus 4x plus 5 and minus x
squared plus 6x plus 17 it's not dropped
our pencil on the ground okay now I
think I named these right f of X and G
of X and then you're ahead of time and
you're working out what's going on but
for the rest of you let me show you how
it is that we get this how we actually
calculate it f of X and G of X that's
our red one there f of X and this is our
blue one G of X okay now we've seen
before we're going to need to work out
where does the area start that's this
the x value that corresponds to this
point and where does our area end so
that's the x value that corresponds to
this point well once we've got that
though suppose we were to integrate I'll
put it in red again integrate let's call
them from A to B the area underneath f
of X all right let's suppose that's what
we were doing
what would the area look like that we've
evaluated well it's going to be
underneath that concave up parabola so
I'm going to shade it in red let's do
this okay so this is the area we're
going to get yeah so this is not the
area that we want but it's related to
the area that we want if I integrate f
of X from A to B I'll get this red area
but if I integrate G from that same set
of boundaries I'm going to get
everything underneath the blue curve all
the way down to the x-axis so you can
see I'm going to need something bigger
this time that would be inclusive of
everything that you can see fitting
underneath the blue parabola rock I was
never very good at coloring between the
lines can't you tell there we go so
there's my blue area right now in order
to get the Green
that you saw her above I'm gonna use a
trick that we learnt the other day which
is to subtract these two areas right the
green area is the blue one take away the
red one the green area is the blue one
take away the red one let's state that
okay the red area is the integral of f
of X and the blue area is the integral
of G of X right so the actual area that
I want area is going to be equal to from
A to B whatever that happens to me we'll
work that out in a second I just want to
make sure we've got our path through the
question right of the blue one we're
gonna do the blue one take away the red
one right so that's going to be G of X
DX and I'm going to subtract the the red
area let's transition colors so from A
to B f of X DX okay so you can see
another way of saying it is I'm going to
have the top function and I'm going to
subtract the bottom function and it is
important that you know which one is
which if I for example did f of X take
away G of X I'm not going to get the
blue area take away the red area I'm
going to get the red area take away the
blue area I'm noticing that the blue
area is larger clearly from the radio
because it includes the red area and
you're gonna get something negative okay
and so that's not going to be the answer
that we want so therefore this order
really matters it's the top takeaway the
bottom